this midnight hundred assalamualaikum
peace be with you I'm in your hosts
you're watching the Deen show and today
some bold statements some bold facts
you're not God I'm not God Your Mama's
not God your wife's not God he's not
gosh she's not God nothing in the
creation is God neither is Jesus peace
be upon him whose beloved to our hearts
he was a mighty Messenger of God who
delivered the same message as all the
prophets of God did worship the One God
unseen God doesn't walk eat sleep he's
not like you or me so we're going to be
discussing this important fact that
Jesus is not God nor the Son of God nor
equal to God in any which way I told you
to some bold behold statements but facts
when we come back here on a detail sit
tight
I'm looking at this card and I don't see
a shake I don't see mallanna but I see
the president you the President of India
my sha-la-la-la Co how are you la
allakum assalaam would have a play but
God I'm sorry we're just trying to break
a little bit of the ice I'm so happy
people have seen the show we've done
before you the president of the IR EF
the Islamic Educational Foundation
Institute Islamic Research & Education
Foundation much a lot and I mentioned
this before I'm very happy I've got to
work with you before and getting to work
with you again and masha'Allah that many
people they put on these titles but
you're just happy being called brother
which if you have others who are called
Mufti mallanna's share and many people I
mean you'd qualify too but to some
extent you just call yourself brother
Imran mark now thank you again and we're
going to get straight down to the top
because time is very short and you heard
me open the topic and I clearly said
look many people they take a lot of
these celebrities as gods I don't know
if you've had heard of jay-z he's
promoting this doers diet wilt he's
almost pumping himself up as God so many
of the youth are looking to this man as
a God because everything they do in
their life he's dictating it or a
celebrity or they might look at that
woman
you know they won't prostrate to the
crater but they'll prostrate to the
woman or to the dollar
knowledgable of my love of it so we're
not talking about that today but it's
relevant here because none of that is
God neither is ice mentioned it's a bold
statement but it's a bold fact Jesus
peace be upon him we love him dearly
we're not the Antichrist because we
believe and you'll explain and expound
on this that he's not God nor the Son of
God not equal to God
what do you got to say about this unless
I know that I said :
say to them say to whom yeah I'll get up
o you people of the book or you Jews and
you Kris
ah no come in a column Athene Sawa in
banana WA by jakub for a common term as
between us and you the first of all the
common terms Alana a Buddha illallah
that we worship none except allah
subhanaw taala what is Abaddon abadan
our Baba mildew nila and we take not
from amongst ourselves any lords or any
patterns unto us besides Allah
suvarnanabha fiind of allah but after
you give this message to them if they
turn away after that message for Kola
shadow then say to them bear witness say
to them remember man on the day of
judgement sister on the day of judgment
you are going to be the witness for who
Lucian will say to them bear witness
what witness be unknown Muslim moon I am
a proud Muslim who has bored my will to
the will of Almighty God Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala by submitting to the commands
in the glorious quran in accordance with
the authentic sunnah of muhammad rasool
allah allah allah solemn as understood
and practiced by the beloved companions
Sabich aramta Allah Allah animals my
name is a great confusion about this
mighty messenger the Jesus peace be upon
him but some people they worship him
some people say no he's not God
he's just the Son of God some people
don't even want to go that route so they
stay quiet because their natural
inclination is to only worship the One
God so they know something's fishy here
so they're confused so we want to
address everybody what do we got to say
to clear this fog this total fallacy
about Jesus being God let's give some
bold fat I said facts so we're not
giving fiction this is facts that Jesus
is not the God not God son of God never
to sign up knowing is equal to get wait
to God talk to us come on how do we
prove this see first of all as a Muslim
and on behalf of all the Muslims in the
world many non-muslims especially our
Christian brothers and sisters they have
a misconception that Muslims Islam and
prophet muhammed sallalahu Salam or the
Quran nas Billa may Allah forbid my god
forbid is Antichrist that's not true no
Muslim is a Muslim if he does not love
believe
and revered Jesus Christ my peace be
upon him nor Muslim is a Muslim it's
compulsory for every Muslim on earth to
believe to love and to revere Jesus
Christ may peace be upon him according
to an authentic hadith of Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu Salam
the hadith is recorded in the jamming of
sahiba Sheikh Nasser with in Habana
rahim allah the prophet sallallaahu
sallam said that allah sent 124,000
prophets on the earth since the time of
Adam killed Prophet Muhammad SAW Salaam
Allah sent 124,000 prophets of them
about 300 plus were the messengers of
Allah the results of Allah and of those
prophets Allah Islam said 5 our rule as
in the primary most and those five are
nooh alehsalaam ibrahim alaih-is-salaam
moosa aleihsalaam he's Allah's Salam
Jesus Christ my peace be upon him and
Muhammad's Allah Allah's Salam so in the
house of Islam Jesus Christ my peace be
upon him is in the top primary most
messengers of Allah no Muslim is a
Muslim if he doesn't believe love and
respect Jesus Christ my peace be upon
him it is an article of faith through
the Quran to every Muslim to love
believe and respect Jesus Christ my
peace be upon him we like all the
Christians we believe that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was born miraculously
to Virgin Mary without any male
intervention we believe that Jesus
Christ may peace be upon him gave life
to the dead but by Allah permission we
believe that he healed those who were
born blind and lepers but by God's
permission by Allah's permission and
about the birth of Virgin Mary
yeah Virgin Mary giving birth to Jesus
many Christians do not believe it today
but we Muslims believe it so this is a
belief in Jesus Christ peace be upon him
okay so now we clear that out when we
come back we're gonna have to because
people are like look this guy is not
telling me anything right now about the
proof I want some proves are we gonna
give some food of course it's all about
evidence yeah of course
all right they're holding us to write
back for all this and more here on the
Deen show
Oh show us the way to other squids
this is the D did I mislead this is the
D did
it's a way of life or to us bad the
messenger best of Lincoln show us the
way to alice Chris this is the de pinna
this man this is the D D nervous back
here on the D show with the president of
the Islamic research and educational
foundation my brother and your brother
Imran he's your brother too even if
you're a non-muslim because we're all
brothers in humanity of course of course
so let's get down with it our brothers
in humanity some of them they're just
going along fitting in sliding in on
Sunday and the pastor to priester he's
throwing these verses and they saying
look I in the father one and whoever you
know believeth in me believe it's in the
father or how was the only begotten Son
and whoever believeth in him shall have
eternal life and they're like that's it
Jesus is God what we got to say yeah of
course this is something a it's the
worst blasphemy against Almighty God
that's how a lot since the Quran Allah
says in surah Maryam surah number 19 at
number 88 89 90 91 and 92 Allah says
also billahi min ash-shaitani rajeem
maharaja redmond WA nada and the boast
the day to say the most gracious has
begotten a son like at the j2me Sheikh
and it da it's the dirtiest thing that
anybody can utter against Almighty God
the card osama Watty eternal men who
potential will do what a terrible Oh
Adam if we give the sense of what they
are uttering against the God saying that
the most gracious has begotten a son if
we give the sense of that statement to
the heavens it will burst upon them if
we give it to the earth it will split
asunder take them inside if we give it
to the mountains they will fall down an
utter ruin on the only remaining wada
the day to say that the most gracious
has begotten a son
it's how Allah reacts in the Quran and
unfortunately you must have seen there
are so many Muslims living in the
Western world shamelessly they go to a
Christian friend and does a happy
Christmas as if they are acknowledging
that Allah has begotten a son now Allah
may Allah forbid instead of educating
our Christian friends our Christian
brothers and sisters the 25th December
Jesus Christ was not born Jesus was not
born on 25th December from the biblical
proof from any other proof he was not
born on 25th December instead of saying
that knows Balaam may Allah forbid the
Muslims a happy Christmas
and Allah is reacting it's the dirtiest
thing that anybody can talk about Allah
say that the creator of all that exists
now he has bigger than a Sunday and he
came out of a womb of a woman a lot of
stuff for a lot that he made his mother
he made his mother impure for forty days
then he went to the bathroom these are
things that human beings do
yes of course so that's like bringing
guys to the level I sometimes I speak to
the Christian friend sign and say do you
expect a human being to marry a [ __ ]
I'm in a female dog you don't do you
expect a human being to beget children
from a female dog or a [ __ ] you don't
it sounds so dirty and filthy it's just
the same saying that God baguettes
children from your nature so you mean
like when you have the dog the female
dog is called yeah [ __ ] yeah okay the
[ __ ] is the English word for the female
dog yeah so you you can't expect a human
being to beget children from a [ __ ] the
God how does he do it from the human
beings it's against the very glorious
nature of the Almighty God his Subhanahu
is glorious and pure and coming to the
subject of evidences
see any Christian on the face of the
earth you ask him any Christian what do
you say about Jesus he immediately opens
the Holy Bible he opens it starts
reading this is what it is dead this is
what it is then this is what it is there
I'm sorry for them but our Christian
friends they don't realize that the
Bible they are holding this same Bible
any version of the Bible the Roman
Catholic Bible with the 73 books or the
Protestant Bible
with only the 66 books with these
differences in the Bible and many more
Bibles no Bible on the face of the earth
has a statement which says that Jesus
Christ in his own words in an
unequivocal statement in his own that
speech ever said that I am the God or
worship me not a single statement
neither did he ever say in his own
statement that I died for your sins not
a single statement in any Bible of the
world not a specific fact now its effect
but some of my argue you know what just
to keep this interesting I'm gonna take
the skeptic approach to say look does
the president have to say he's the
president people know he's the president
well yeah I say about that yeah goes in
in one of my discussions in a public
program a Christian friend said you see
mr. Obama is the president of the USA oh
you had this question yeah of course
I've had it so he said you seem so Obama
is the president of the UNC he doesn't
go out to the people and say that I am
the president of the USA so therefore
Jesus need not say I am the God but
these people I mean I I don't know what
in the vocabulary to give them the term
shall I call them ignoring shall I call
them in no sense or shall I call them
people who are totally uneducated what
shall I call them
you're gonna play simple logic and
common sense Obama doesn't need to say
that I am the president of the USA
because the American people elected him
the president but nobody likes a God so
therefore God has to identify himself
and say I am the God every American
knows that President Obama has been
elected by the Americans so he need not
come to every door lock the door and say
and the god but God he's not elected God
is by himself he has to identify to his
servants that I am your God worship me
these are the dudes for you these are
the don'ts for you and you have to
accept it okay that makes a lot of sand
and we're trying not to hurt anyone's
feeling it because I know this can be a
sensitive topic it's out of the love
that we love our brothers in humanity
and we really want to educate them
because we want the best for all mankind
and this is a serious issue - now of
course right we say glory to God glory
to the Creator but to bring him down to
his creation I did this was a very
important
you just pointed out some people feel it
offended I said man it's not offense if
somebody believes 2+2 is 5 and the
mathematics teacher correct says 2 plus
2 is 4 the person believing 2+2 is 5
cannot say I am feeling offended nothing
to offend we are trying to correct you
they're trying to educate you we are
trying our lovely brothers and sisters
the Christian brothers and sisters are
so lovely people on earth we are trying
to tell to them what are you doing you
are an educated people you are the most
developed community on the face of the
earth in the worldly of fails you don't
have simple logic that your Bible
doesn't agree that Jesus Christ my peace
be upon him is the God the Son of God or
anyone equal to the God
so time is short now we have okay you
clearly said that in this Bible this
version many versions some have this in
it some have that that's a different
topic because as soon as you add some of
the lists not the Word of God so now
what we do have from it even in any of
the red letters or any of them there's
no explicit statement where Jesus ever
said I am God submit should be don't of
course should be one in a Trinity I'm
coming to die for your sins if you have
nothing here that will come up okay
every dense astatically from the Bible
okay let's give some he was worshipped
oh they say look Thomas worshiped him
they say that looking in John 1:1 in the
beginning was the word and the word was
a guy and the word came flushed
statements like this they throw these
out there what do we say see it's very
small logic to understand that John 1:1
is generally quoted in the beginning was
the word the Word was with God and the
Word was God so instead of back if you
replace though if word is God just
replaced the word world
with God so it would sound like this in
the beginning was the God and the God
was with God and the God was God is it a
is it a sensible statement to give and
John 1:1 is already a debatable words
people reject the words saying it's an
interpolation nobody knows who wrote
John 1:1 no Christian on the face of the
earth
no Christian believe me no Christian and
there is an infinite percentage
difference between 0 Christian and 1
Christian no Christian on the face of
the earth can ever get an evidence to
say or typically
that John 1:1 is an uncorrupted words
written by John himself no Christian can
do it
it's a corrupted portion in the Bible
and I would like to thank the Christian
publishers who published the red letter
Bible and made the job for people like
me easy in the red lighted Bible in the
words of Jesus they say these are the
words of Jesus so fine I take the red
lighted Bible I try to read read once
twice thrice I try to make a study again
and again and every time I try to make a
study I return back to the conclusion
with a failure of zero saying man not a
single statement in the entire related
Bible - in regulators where Jesus said
and God and the Son of God in the
literal sense worship me or I died for
your sins or I am one of the Trinity
even the word Trinity does not occur in
the Bible anyway that will come back and
check we're gonna see we gotta take a
break just one more before we go to
break that he was worship and he didn't
say stop he didn't stop people follows
me oh no I heard this yeah the
Christians say that there are so many
verses which I am going to coat with
deny that he ever said I am God or he
very tried to portray himself as God or
where people worshiped him not a signal
these are all corrupted portions in the
Bible okay we're gonna be back to cover
this and more here in the Deen show
we'll be right back
show us the word to all the screens this
is the dhih dhih this is the deal
back here on the Dean show with the
president of the I are EF and this is
what you've dedicated your life to
helping out of the love our brothers in
humanity help to understand what indeed
the truth is and what's opposite of
truth and his opposite to say that God
had a son was a man because the crater
is the crater where his creation where
his creatures and we need to worship God
that made God a part of us or sit here
and belittle him in that way so we're
giving proves that Jesus peace be upon
him is not God the Son of God or ever
have any equality with God and before we
left I was just trying to you know give
some some evidences that people will use
and they'll say look Thomas because I
mentioned something about people
worshipping him he said my Lord and my
god so look he was called my Lord and my
god what do you got to say about this
yeah so you see this is Jesus himself
clarifies that because Thomas said Lord
and my god so Jesus is God but you look
in the Gospel of Matthew chapter number
19 verse number 16 17 18 when you read
it a person comes to Jesus and he says
oh good master not God he says good
master and Jesus is responding why do
you call me good you look at the
response of Jesus why do you call me
good there is none good except one that
is the God Jesus does not want anyone
even to call him good leave aside Jesus
asking anyone to call it God Jesus is
saying why do you call me good there is
none good except one that is the God so
calling somebody God at that time was
very common as in our times today it was
coming it was common even in our times
today I'm saying when we go to the
courtroom in the court there are so many
times the people referred to the judge
there the Honorable Judge they say oh my
lord that's like in UK in London yeah so
does that mean that Lord means to
almighty god lord mountbatten does that
mean that lord is almighty god it's the
usage of the language so Jesus never
ever understood that when Thomas said
God he was trying to say in the sense
that Jesus is Almighty God and therefore
Jesus didn't react to it
but when the police is good he says why
callest thou me good there is none good
except one that is the Almighty God this
is now something that they can verify in
what verse what Matthew chapter number
19 was number 16 17 and 18 okay now
moving on moving along because we're
almost out of time he talks about that I
and the father are one oh yeah what you
gotta say about that is that that is the
words when we muslims tell our Christian
brothers and sisters you see Jesus never
said and God so they could you see in
John Jesus said I and my father are one
if you read Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 30 that is the
words but the code Gospel of John yes
chapter number 10 was number third so
you even know this verse oh yeah the
context comes from verse number 23 Jesus
enters the Solomons Jesus enters a
temple of its time it's worshiping place
of its time and the people are gathered
there is a discussion taking place then
in verse number 29
Jesus says Gospel of John chapter number
10 verse number 29 Jesus says my father
is greater than all in verse number 30
he says I and the father are one you see
when you read surah nisa in the Quran
surah number 4 at number 88 0 Allah says
whoever obeys mohammed salah assalam
obeys allah the muslim never
misunderstood thinking that muhammad and
al are the same so Allah is Allah in the
Mission Prophet Muhammad and Allah
subhana Allah were the same when Jesus
says I and my father are one it means in
the mission we are one not in person
because when Jesus says I and my father
are one you see the confusion went to
the Jews of his time verse number 31 the
context continues Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 31 the Jews
picked up the stones to heat and Jesus
verse number 32 Jesus is inquiring
what's the matter what's the problem why
do you want to heat at me do I not do
good works in the name of the Father
will sent me verse number 33 the Jews
are responding they say we don't heat at
you for the good works we heat at you
because you bless me you did to say you
are the son of God so Jesus says in
verse number 34 gospel of john chapter
number 10
he says is it not mentioned in your
scripture that whoever does the work of
God are the sons of God when I say on
the son of God what is the problem I'm
just speaking the same language that you
understand you people know whoever does
the work of God are the sons of God and
believe me I am not joking
believe me the Bible gives sense to the
God by tons their sons what you're
saying by turns
yes they're our sons by tons to the God
in the Bible for example when you read
the book of Hosea chapter number
chapter number one verse number ten book
of Hosea chapter number one verse number
ten Book of Jeremiah chat number nine
verse number 26 it says the children of
Israel are the sons of God when you read
the book of Deuteronomy chapter 32 verse
number 6 it says the sons and the
daughters of God when you read the book
of Exodus chapter 4 verse number 22 it
says even Israel is my firstborn when
you read the Book of Psalms chapter
number 68 verse number 5 it says the
orphans are the sons of God when you
read the Book of Psalms chapter number
82 verse number 6 it says the judges and
the jurists are the sons of God when you
read the Book of Psalms chapter number
89 verse number 26 and 27 it says David
is the son of God when you read the book
of new Gospel of Luke chapter number 3
verse number 38 it says Adam is the son
of God when you read Gospel of John
chapter number 1 verse number 12 it says
whoever receives Jesus are the sons of
God you see Bible has got sons to the
God by tons so we're here actually with
the President of the irf who's actually
your scholar of Christianity we could
say that because you've been studying
Christianity I've never heard a
Christian priest or pastor anyone really
give the references and someone can go
check it up it's very hard and rare to
find someone you know you really been
studied it's a stimuli xur to me
somebody would say you're the scholar of
the Bible and the student of the Quran
it's scholar of the Bible and a student
it makes me very energetic when somebody
says that all right all right let's go
on we're almost out of time tell us now
one more one more one more he said
whoever seen me seen the father I was
supposed to be saying whoever seeing me
seen the father
Oh again that's that's an action because
the same Jesus then if
believe whoever has seen me has seen the
father the same Jesus in the red
Layton's Gospel of John chapter five
verse number 37 he says no man has ever
seen him or heard his voice can you
imagine that no man has ever seen him or
heard his voice and in the hospital John
chat number five verse number 30 31 and
32 Jesus says I can of mine own shall do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just because I seek not my
will but the will of the Father well
sent me and father was a common term in
those times to be used for the God
commonly every person called the God as
the father not just Jesus and now when
you see the Quran Allah says in the
Quran in surah nisa surah number 4 at
number 171 ya al al kitab or you people
of the book you jews and christians
lotta loose Edina come do not go to
excesses in your religion well as a
coluan Allah Allah Allah Allah
and do not say anything about Allah
except the truth in the Magma's you is
of no Maria Marsol Allah he most
certainly crises as the son of Mary was
the Messenger of Allah
what Colima to who and a bird from him
his command he was born by his command
Lemuria mawaru who knew that Allah
bestowed upon Mary and a spirit
proceeding from him for I mean who Bill
Nighy mercifully all of you didn't
believe in Allah and all his messengers
voilá of hulu selasa
don't say Trinity into he'll come if you
leave it it's good for you in the Malawi
now avoid most certainly your God is
only one Allah subhana wa iyyaka Nala
who wanna
glory be to him that he does not beget a
son it does not befit to him to beget a
son l'homme ma is some avati mama fill
up everything in the heavens and the
earth belong to him and Allah reacts
again ensure a ma'idah
surah number 5 has number 72 Allah says
look at the cover ala zina allah allahu
allah ma SI o Maryam whoever said that
Christ Jesus is Allah they did blaspheme
they disbelieved what Carl Massey who
insect Christ Jesus said Colin Massey
who ya bani israel abdullah horribly
were a bucum oh you children of israel
worship allah who is my god and your God
in the Hohmann you should build life
animala Ileana whosoever will associate
any partners with Allah subhana Allah
Allah will forbid heaven for them
forever Verma vahana they will be thrown
in the Hellfire as a punishment for
being treacherous to the Almighty God
Vimala slalom imminence are and they're
these disbelievers these oppressors this
Terry Nix against Allah will not find
any helpers for them Allah says in surah
- remember 5 at number 75 Allah subhana
Allah says man Masuku Maryam Allah rasul
christ jesus the son of mary was no more
than a messenger but Mugu Sabiha and his
mother was a pious woman was a truthful
woman kana yakulani Tom Allah says they
both ate food - oh boy you know whom
Allah hiya look how clear we make our
science and to you so man thor had
another look kun where are you getting
perverted away do that does the God
require to eat eating is a human nature
when you eat metabolism and catabolism
takes place and you send out what you
don't need in your body does God do all
this rubbish I lie saying what happened
to you God is the purest look and ponder
on all this ok we gotta go we're out of
time just I got a squeeze this end they
say you're not full of the Holy Ghost
that's why you don't understand oh I'm
thankful to Allah that I'm not full of
the Holy Ghost I don't need to be full
of the Holy Ghost and filled with the
holy word and that is enough for me
mashallah see Holy Ghost comes to so
many people in the world but the people
are not understanding that what you call
as the Holy Ghost is taking you away
from the fundamentals that Jesus taught
in the Bible that there is no God except
one in Gospel of John chapter number 17
verse number three and four he says this
is life eternal that they might know
thee the only true God and Jesus whom
you have sent
I have glorified your name on earth I
have finished the job is you gave me to
do and I would like to give the best
definition of the Almighty God
anyone you worship except Allah has God
fit that sample whether Jesus or any
other Tom Dick and Harry fit it to that
criteria if it fits it's God otherwise
it
not God Allah says in surah a class
surah number 9 and 12 at number 1 2 4
pull say to them who Allah who had he is
Allah the only one Allah whose Samad he
is independent he doesn't need anything
he is totally independent of all needs
but everyone besides him need him alone
Lanyon Latvala mueller he does not beget
children nor is He begotten wallah
yaqula lahu coupon earth and there is
none like unto him and for your
information the word begotten son
the word begotten that was in Gospel of
John chapter number 3 verse number 16
the Revised Standard Version three you
out that word said it's an interpolation
it's a corruption it's a concoction in
the Bible they said try not the three or
the would-be coordinates no more there
they are coming closer to Islam Subhan
Allah
let them come closer and read the Kalima
lillah just in 15 seconds look we're
past our time so people don't feel
awkward they feel like you know what
even many of the Anglican bishops they
came to a unanimous decision that you
don't have to say Jesus is God just and
you can be bishops there was a shocking
survey in England the Anglican bishops
of England they have agreed that Jesus
is not God he is not the Son of God and
he is not equal to God let my Christian
brothers and sisters not mistaken me to
be an anglican bishop and not an
anglican bishop and a step ahead of the
Anglican bishops they agreed that Jesus
is not the God he is not the Son of God
is not equal to God what they need to
agree is Allah is the only one God who
created Jesus who created Adam Noah
Mohamed Salah Salam and everything in
the universe besides Allah is the
creation of Allah he is the only one God
thank you very much not Allah peace we
end with peace peace be with you
assalamualaikum waalaikumussalam Africa
and thank you for since height to
another episode of D show we love you we
love all of mankind but we don't like
certain things that people do and it's
not about doing what we want to do is
about doing what God wants us to do so
the most corrupting at an individual the
most extreme thing that the individual
human being can do is worship other than
the Creator to set up an equal a partner
to God and this is what Jesus called the
people away from we
Jesus and we love you too that's why
we're trying to educate you because we
want the best for you so only worship
the God that Jesus worship and not
worship the creation or the creatures of
God worship the one who created
everything that exists and we gave you
some more evidences and proofs so you
can ponder and reflect over but the main
thing you have to do is to submit
yourself and humbly ask the Creator him
alone to guide you and make things clear
and that is how the truth will be
enlightening you and we'll see you next
time here in the Dean show until then
peace be unto you